this debate centers on national security
and on the safety of our constituents
and there'll be differences of view
within and between every party in this
house so in good faith and conscience
members will reach different conclusions
anybody who approaches today's debate
without the gravest doubts reservations
and anxieties simply hasn't been paying
attention but we're set here by our
constituents to exercise our best
judgment each our own best judgment this
is the debate of contradictions the
terms of today's motion occurring the UN
resolution are stone almost apocalyptic
in the threat they describe as an
unprecedented threat to international
peace and security but the proposal
before us amounts as my honourable
friend forgotten said only to a
relatively minor extension and action we
are already undertaking we're being
asked to agree to act both in Iraq and
Syria precisely because that is what -
doomed and their headquarters is in
Syria we're being asked to make a
further contribution to an existing
international effort to contain - from
extending the mayhem and bloodshed that
accompanies their every move even more
widely across the Middle East serious
questions are being raised and I respect
those who raised them there is unease
about ground forces there is proper
concern about the strategy and endgame
and about the aftermath about rebuilding
some say simply that innocent people are
more likely to be killed military action
does create casualties however much we
try to minimize them so should we on
those grounds abandon action in Iraq
although we undertake it at the request
of Iraq's government and it does seem to
be making a difference should we take no
further action
- who are themselves killing innocent
people and striving to kill more every
day of the week or should we simply
leave it to others would we make
ourselves a bigger target for dire
attack we are a target we will remain a
target there's no need to wonder about
it - has told us so and continues to
tell us so with every day that passes we
may as well take them not just at their
word but indeed at their deeds they have
sought out our fellow countrymen and
women to kill including aid workers and
other innocents and whatever we decide
today there is no doubt that they will
do so again nor is the consequence of
inaction simply - controlling more
territory more land we've seen what
happens where they take control the
treatment of groups such as these
Yazidis in all its horror should surely
make us unwilling to contemplate any
further extension of - controlled
territory in action
- leads that way to death and
destruction
quite separately there are those not
opposed in principle to action who doubt
the efficacy of what is proposed a
coalition action which rests almost
wholly on bombing they say will have
little effect well tell that to the
customs and don't forget that if there
had been no bombing in Kosovo perhaps a
million Albanian Muslim refugees would
have been seeking refuge in Europe tell
that to the Kurds in kobani who if
memory serves pleaded for international
air support without which they felt they
were losing control to - tell them in
Sierra Leone that military action should
always be avoided because there would be
casualties their state and their peace
were almost destroyed it was British
military action that brought them back
from the brink of course it took place
in conjunction with political and
diplomatic activity and I share the view
that it's vital that such activity is
substantially strengthened and I was
heartened by what the prime minister
told us today our conference did call
for a United Nations resolution before
further action and we now have a
unanimous Security Council resolution
moreover that resolution calls on member
states in explicit and unmistakable
terms to combat dioecious threat and I
quote by all means and it calls - and
again I quote for us to eradicate the
safe haven they have established in Iraq
and Syria those are the words of the UN
resolution and though it speaks of the
need to pursue the peace process the
United Nations resolution calls on
member states to act now moreover our
French allies have explicitly asked us
for such support and I invite the house
to consider how we would feel and what
we would say
if what took place in Paris had happened
in London if we had explicitly asked
France for support and France had
refused these are genuinely extremely
I'm sorry no these are genuinely
extremely difficult as well as extremely
serious decisions but it is the urgings
of the United Nations and of the
socialist government in France that for
me have been the tipping point in my
decision to support
manaphy action